esta vez nos dicen que gdx es igual a
equis cuadrada más 5 x 3 y que h de
james es igual a 3 que multiplican a ye
menos 1 al cuadrado menos 5 y lo que nos
piden es h
de menos seis ahora bien tal vez la
manera en la que está escrito esto se te
haga un poco extraño sobre todo este
pequeño circulito que tenemos aquí pero
este circuito el que está entre la h
lage es nuestro símbolo que representa
la composición de funciones composición
de funciones muy bien así que no debes
preocuparte por este pequeño círculo que
tenemos aquí porque esto es exactamente
lo mismo que reescribir lo de la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que
poder escribir h deje de -6 déjame
ponerlo así primero vamos a agarrar la
función g y se la vamos a aplicar a
menos 6
-6 de lujo déjame ponerlo con sus
respectivos colores esto va a ser igual
y después a este g de -6 le vamos a
aplicar la función h le vamos a aplicar
la función h de tal manera que éste
circulito lo que me representa es
exactamente lo mismo que tengo en la
derecha h deje de -6 es lo mismo que h
de g de menos 6 sólo escucha como lo
estoy leyendo y bueno en lo personal
encuentro mucho más intuitiva esta
segunda anotación pero es bueno que te
familiarices con este símbolo de la
composición de funciones porque este
pequeño círculo puede ser que te lo
encuentres en algún momento y no quiero
que te estreses no deberías estresarte
porque recuerda que esto va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que escribirlo como
está del lado derecho ahora a que es
igual h
deje de -6 bueno sólo tenemos que
recordar que esto significa tomar
al número menos 6 lo voy a poner aquí al
número menos 6 ya este número meterlo en
la función g vamos a meterlo en nuestra
función g en nuestra función g que por
cierto esto nos va a dar g de menos 6 y
ya que tengamos a g de menos 6 sea cual
sea el número o el valor que nos dé
justo eso es lo que vamos a averiguar en
un segundo esto mismo lo vamos a meter
en la función h déjame ponerlo así lo
vamos a meter en nuestra función h para
que nos dé de respuesta h de quien deje
de -6 de la función gm que está aplicada
a su vez al número menos seis muy bien
entonces simplemente tenemos que hacer
un paso a la vez porque muchas veces
cuando empiezas a ver esto por primera
vez se ve muy complicado y confuso pero
recuerda lo único que tienes que hacer
es respirar hondo y después hacer un
paso a la vez así que empecemos por
averiguar cuánto es gd -6 y bueno eso es
muy sencillo porque solamente vamos a
evaluar el número en esta función y
luego lo que obtengamos sea el valor que
sea vamos a meterlo en la función h y
eso nos llevará a otro valor
pero bueno empecemos averiguando cuánto
es gd menos 6 déjenme escribirlo
queremos saber cuánto es
de menos 6 de menos 6 y bueno lo único
que tenemos que hacer es evaluar en esta
función así que me voy a tomar al menos
6 lo voy a poner aquí lo voy a elevar al
cuadrado al menos 6 lo vamos a elevar al
cuadrado ya esto habrá que sumarle 5 x
menos 65 x menos 6 y después me dice la
función que a esto hay que quitarle 3
entonces a esto le vamos a quitar 3 y ya
cuánto es igual esto bueno menos 6 al
cuadrado es 36 positivo y después tengo
más x menos es menos 5 por 6 es 30 am -
3 es decir esto es lo mismo que 36 menos
33 lo cual me da 3 positivo así que
quede menos 6 ya sabemos que vale 3 g de
menos 6 ya sabemos que vale 3 aquí
podemos poner también el valor de 3 y
ahora lo único que necesitamos es
la h de 3 porque nosotros pusimos menos
6 en la función g y obtuvimos de salida
3 entonces ahora este 3 lo vamos a meter
a la función h y vamos a obtener h de
tres así que veamos cuánto es h de en
esta ocasión de tres y bueno vamos a
hacerlo utilizando la definición de h h
de cualquier valor es igual a tres veces
ese valor menos uno al cuadrado menos
cinco así que esto va a ser igual a tres
que multiplican déjame ponerlo así menos
53 que multiplican a 3 - 1 al cuadrado a
3 - 1 - 1 todo esto elevado al cuadrado
y eso menos 5 ok y esto va a ser lo
mismo que 3 que multiplica 3 - 1 es 2 2
al cuadrado 3 que multiplicados al
cuadrado menos 5 lo cual es lo mismo que
es por 4 menos 5 y esto es lo mismo que
12 - 5 que es igual a 7 y hemos
terminado
empezamos con menos 6 lo metimos en la
función g y obtuvimos 3 y después
aquella salida de la función que lo
metimos en la función h y obtuvimos 7
así que todo esto es lo mismo que 7
obtuvimos 7 esto es lo mismo que 7 todo
resultó ser igual a 7
entonces h de menos 6 es lo mismo que 7
o dicho de otra manera h
deje de menos 6 es lo mismo que 7 pones
como entrada al menos 6 adentro de la
función g y lo que obtienes de salida lo
pone de nuevo de entrada en la función h
y obtienes el valor de 7